la cantine sera-t-elle vraiment moins
cher à la rentrée prochaine pour 8000
petits tours enjaux question au menu du
conseil municipal de lundi la
municipalité va en effet doubler le
nombre de tranches du quotient familial
qui sert aux calculs du prix des repas
un coup de pouce supplémentaire pour les
plus modestes mais qui laisse
l'opposition sur sa fin Romainville
jusqu'en 2022 tout aurait été la seule
ville française de plus de 100000
habitants ne pas mettre en place un
quotient familial sur le prix des repas
à la cantine 5 tranches en 2022 calquées
sur celle de la CAF pour la rentrée 2023
il en aura 10 on va de de 70 centimes à
5,20 donc avec une gradation
suffisamment fine pour éviter les effets
de seuil le coût de du service est
d'environ 10 euros donc même pour ceux
donc qui payent le tarif le plus cher la
solidarité joue énormément on est plutôt
sur un coup même lorsque c'est sur la
tranche supérieure qui est inférieure
aux villes de de la même strate donc on
reste à tour sur quelque chose d'assez
modéré pour l'opposition le compte n'y
est pas elle dénonce des augmentations
substantielles par rapport à l'ancien
système un tarif unique à 3,35 qui
pouvait être compensé par une aide du
Centre Communal d'Action Sociale
très surprenant c'est la hausse assez
forte sur les autres tarifs on est sur
des hausses de 15% sur les tranches et
sur la restauration scolaire à partir du
moment le quotient familial était mis en
place on avait le monde et nous est-ce
que le CCAS puisse continuer à porter de
l'aide comme c'était le cas auparavant
et bien c'était des supprimer et
d'ailleurs le budget du CSS est en
baisse pour cette année sujet au combien
épineux le prix de la cantine sera
débattu en conseil municipal lundi à
Tours plus de 8200 enfants fréquentent
le restaurant scolaire